the VW bus has been a coke car since the
1950s and the revamped e5 multi van is
worthy of its illustrious ancestors with
no lack of confidence
VW calls its cars simply the car so it
might as well call the t5 the bus the T
on VW s commercial vehicle stands for
transporter but the bus is lifestyle
incarnate for highly mobile people from
families to nomads
then we're debating contest and Montes
kirat concedes the multiband is ideal
for anyone who needs space for any
reason professional or private for a
conference room or a camper for big
families he can't think of many cars
that accommodate seven people and
luggage besides the t5 all-purpose
design is timeless and not entirely
without elegance and is practical for
everyday use hardly any other van is as
flexible in how its interior can be used
that's been the secret of the VW buses
success for nearly 65 years
the space is the thing and the seats are
comfortable and then some the fold-out
Center table may not be a new idea but
it's practical the cargo space reaches a
maximum of 4500 liters but only with all
the furniture removed which one person
alone can't easily do the seats are
heavy and maneuvering the seats and
benches out the doors takes both
coordination and elbow grease
on request the center console can
accommodate a multimedia system with
Bluetooth and satellite navigation
avoid and Montes points out that even if
the two meter wide and five meter long
multi van isn't the sleekest car
it's simple contours make it easy to
maneuver garden for mandazi amoebas each
dish we tested the biggest TSI
gasoline-powered engine with 150
kilowatts giving the t5 lots of pickup
and temperament pw's two-liter turbo can
push the van from zero to 100 kilometers
an hour and nine point five seconds
Deb starting with Montes takes that as a
very decent time for a multiband even if
it takes lots of fuel to do it the
diesels in the range available are quite
a bit more efficient but no less nimble
and the maximum torque of 350 Newton
metres is not to be sneezed at the dual
clutch transmission in the van we tested
changes gears swiftly and easily and
perfect harmony with a powerful engine
Montes likes the VW buses high seat
position and the better view the driver
has of obstacles coming up one of the
biggest obstacles comes up right on the
showroom floor that t5 s list price
starting at a good thirty-two thousand
euros in Germany the 2-liter TSI engine
version we tested with a dual clutch
transmission costs a whole twenty
thousand euros more and it doesn't end
there
the lavishly equipped Business Edition
commands a business class 120,000 euro
price tag for month Atlanta says the
interior looks nice but the t5 is still
a utility vehicle flight type I'm not
sponsored but it's one that can be lots
of fun the VW bus still bashed and some
of the glow and nostalgia of the day and
driving one is still something special
as it's likely to be for generations to
come
you